thank you I'm glad to see you here and i
hope the talk will be somehow useful to
you and first before I start I would
like to know like how to make this talk
more relevant to you so may I ask you a
question who of you are medical doctors
clinicians right researchers
epidemiologists okay great great any
other practitioners like psychologists
social workers oh great ok welcome all
right all right so I see that we have a
number of researchers and some medical
doctors will try and adjust the focus so
in this talk we I really hope that it
will be kind of interactive I don't
really want to lecture from the Tribune
and if you have questions please you're
more than welcome to us can interrupt me
and if you want to clarify something or
you have a question just right in the
middle of the talk and so we'll go over
the talk is devoted to hiv-related
stigma in health care settings and first
what we do we will bring a little update
on what HIV AIDS is I'm sure you are
very familiar with what it is but just
quickly to be on the same page then we
talk about epidemic and global
perspective and we'll focus particularly
in Russia because this study was done in
Russian and then we will talk about that
I think that's going to be kind of core
of the talk is that what stigma is what
discrimination is what hiv-related
stigma and discrimination czar and we're
going to bring an example of study that
was as Robert said my master thesis
project and I'm going to present the
result
of the study in the style of a
manuscript so we go over this will be
our background section we'll go over
study medicine objectives and then we
will see the results and discussion will
this do okay Oh Lizzy okay so a few
abbreviations which are going to use
throughout the talk I'm sure you're
familiar with them first csw commercial
sex worker intravenous drug user or
intravenous drug use IDU men who have
sex with men MSM and hiv+ will mean HIV
positive pneus that's individual is HIV
positive quick update I'm sure you know
that HIV is human immunodeficiency virus
is a causative agent of 8 the virus
multiplies in particular cell line
within the body and causing syndrome
which is called AIDS and before mid 90s
HIV infection and aids was nearly
hundred percent lethal but things
changed in 1995 late 92 95 or 96 when
the antiretroviral therapy became
available so called highly active
antiretroviral therapy and with it which
halts replication of the virus
technically having the therapy nowaday
we should have know any single case of
AIDS but I'm sure I'm sure you know that
we do have still cases of AIDS and we
have AIDS related mortality and
partially it's explained by the topic of
our talk by the HIV AIDS related stigma
more of the backgrounds I'm here three
routes of transmission of HIV
blood-borne sexual and from mother to
child for blood-borne it's intravenous
drug use either blood transfusion or
professional contact we're going to
focus a bit more on professional contact
here are the numbers of the which can
give you idea about the risk so here's
the question what is more infectious HIV
or hep b hepatitis b viral hepatitis B
hepatitis B yes so for if we take the
typical professional risk percutaneous
needlestick exposure so if we have a
syringe syringe needle and prick the
skin the risk of acquiring HIV given
that there is HIV in the needle is point
three percent means one out of three
hundred cases you prick 300 individuals
and only one will be infected with
Herbie do you know what the number will
look like Robert knows anyone else
twenty percent yes twenty to thirty
percent meaning one in five one and
three so it's considerably considerably
more than that but what is perceived as
more dangerous as more infections often
HIV is procida perceived as more
infectious and why is that there is no
simple answer why is that but one of the
answer answers is that HIV hit
especially in the beginning and even
nowadays in certain countries in certain
settings is little e we have 33 million
people who are HIV positive on earth and
so far we have 25 million individuals
who died due to eight because of such
immense epidemic in this epidemic
produced a serious global response and I
think it's a good trend that the number
of aids-related deaths declining though
it should be 0 but at least it's even if
it's not zero it is declining everywhere
in the world besides you can guess where
yes besides Eastern Europe and Russia
particularly and in the world number of
new cases new HIV cases is declining
everywhere in the world besides you know
where
that's my fam I'm sure many of you have
seen that so this is prevalence of HIV
in Russia or has intermediate prevalence
which is estimated to be somewhere
between point five and one percent
here's a slide to illustrate that trends
in Russia are not so good these are a
number of people who died with it died
from AIDS it's related deaths number of
weights related deaths and you see that
the only region where we have a really
prominent trend to increase in this
number is Eastern Europe and to give you
idea that like geographically Russia and
Ukraine make ninety percent of the
Eastern Europe and in regards of the HIV
related statistics Russia and Ukraine
also make ninety percent of all the
statistics so that means these figures
are basically Russia and Ukraine HIV
epidemic in Russia is not well
controlled we have a few records one of
them is largest regional increase in
number of people living with hiv/aids
and we hold this record for several
years in their own another particular
feature of hiv/aids epidemic and Rush is
that it was related to intravenous drug
use so here's the question what was the
engine what was the what force was what
route of transmission was driving
epidemic in the US especially in the
beginning
what truth was the most common popular
in the US yeah yeah men who have sex
with men homosexual transmission what
truth is the most common in Africa
heterosexual yes Eastern Europe we have
our own way it's intravenous drug use so
the epidemic from the very beginning has
specific features but now we have
process which is called generalization
and i'm sure those who are
epidemiologists know that this means
that epidemic from the core group which
in the US was men who have sex with men
in russia it's a group of population of
ID use it expands to the general
population that's called generalization
and this process usually leads to really
a big increase in number of cases unless
prevention measures are taken so that's
an update on HIV infection in russia do
you have any questions in that regard
because now we're going to move to the
stigma park
just another thing well this is map of
Russia and the prevalence of HIV do you
see kind of trend by diagonal going from
here up to the north so knowing
political situation in Eurasia and
knowing that HIV epidemic was driven
primarily via ID you why do you think we
have this trend what's that poppies who
drugged yes exactly exactly that's drug
trafficking route from Afghanistan
somewhere here in below that's how the
drugs transported
so now stigma and discrimination so
stigma and discrimination what is stigma
I mean not what is written on the slide
but what is stigma for you yeah here is
the definition of hiv-related stigma but
stigma can be related to anything to
race ethnicity sexual orientation age
what is stigma
perfect perfect stigma are translated
from Greek means label so stigma means
labeling labeling a group labeling part
of the group are with certain mark
meaning separating individuals from the
group that's what stigma is and
hiv-related stigma is by wh 0 definition
is devaluation of people either living
with HIV or somehow associated with
hiv/aids and what is discrimination in
general yeah please oh no it's part of
our service well well well it happens
everywhere yeah it happens everywhere
what is discrimination
ah yes please exactly exactly so
discrimination is the result of stigma
first by stigma we somehow separate
group into I don't know larger usually
smaller part we separate and then if we
act towards these members somehow
differently this is going to be
discrimination and I've heard like words
like sad poor treatment discrimination
not necessarily means satin poor
discrimination by itself is a sort of
neutral term but historically it's got a
negative kind of coloring to it
discrimination can be sometimes can be
good and we going to go over it why and
when it is good so I think that's it for
this slide but if we go by traditional
way of perceiving stigma and
discrimination as negative and usually
stigma and discrimination are negative
phenomenons in HIV medicine or health
care or HIV related I don't know world
consequences of stigma usually bad first
it's a lower quality of care stigma and
discrimination can result in lower
quality of care and even up to refusal
so there are many cases many cases that
I witnessed that people were refused to
be given medical care second this is
easy to understand lower quality refusal
easy okay we treat this we don't treat
this drug users or someone else go up
reduced accessibility of care why do you
think it is and as a result lower
treatment that reluctance to participate
in treatment and prevention program why
do you think is it is consequence of
stigma why do think stigma
discrimination
results in lower treatment adherence
it's like immersive conditioning if
you've gone to a clinic and received
poor treatment there felt insulted
you're not
exactly if you go to a place where the
services are provided with lower quality
or you were treated somehow the under
the standard and yes you will not go
there again that's very simple very
simple also I mean and very important
distinction it's not about actual
quality of care it all it's all about
the perceived quality of care how do I
feel in this clinic that's very
important distinction not exactly I mean
they are interrelated but they not the
same so my willingness to come back to
the place I don't know that any place
sharp clinic yes I don't know
hairdresser whatever depends on my
feelings not maybe which are not
necessarily exactly the way the clinic
is set and well and the consequences
stigma discrimination promotes the
spread of the epidemic and that's why
that's why knowing and dealing with
stigma discrimination trying to diminish
to decrease it is very important
we move on are you okay all right all
right so last time we I think we do we
agree that stigma hiv-related stigma is
bad okay we hopefully we agree on that
but why it does exist why does exist we
know that it is bad we like in general
people are I know trying to behave
nicely trying to be nice and why we
still discriminate against people living
with HIV yes exactly exactly exactly HIV
inherits the stigma of the of the
stigmatized groups like drug users like
men who have sex with men and so on
commercial sex workers so groups that
are generally stigmatized and they are
they it happened that these groups were
related to HIV and that's why that's one
of the reasons but that's the i would
say that's kind of historical reason but
there is another reason for why stigma
exists alright that I'm just thinking
that it's entirely store behind with
racism xenophobia it may not happen
yes but it may happen in the
subconscious level where somebody really
does have good intentions but perfect
what may happen in this system perfect
where maybe where there is a minority
population the facilities are invincible
as another
and it takes time yes yes it's
definitely multi-level issue and one of
the levels which I'm actually going to
talk a bit more on is a categorization
the phenomenon which is called
categorization and this is a kind of
stigma generating property of our brain
our brain is made I mean I and yes and
you can see the references here and if
you want you can read more about that I
these are this property of our brain was
proved in number of studies so our brain
tends to categorize things why why would
you categorize
why I mean it's it's like natural
phenomenon we categorize exactly it
simplifies its speed speeds up the
process it makes our life easier we
categorize it's easy when we have black
and white it's easy when we have tall
and short it is when we have rich and
poor okay you reach your poor done move
on so that's natural a property of our
brain that's right but it has to be kept
in mind when we approach a patient where
we approach a client when we do a study
that it's a natural property of our
brain our brain really easily slips to
that way so we have to control it
without the controlling the going to
categorization we can really easily slip
to stigmatizing people so that's if you
want to take home message I would
suggest taking this so that our brain
has natural property to categorize and
because of the categorization
categorization can result in stigma and
there are many ways to deal with it and
what will be the easiest
I would say that if we try not to assume
too much and just try and ask people if
we talk to people they can tell us very
interesting things which will not
actually follow our patterns that we
have for them in our brain okay okay
yeah I can talk more about that because
I mean I really like this talk but we
should we should move on I mean if you
are interested we can discuss it later
after the presentation well there is
another argument why hiv-related stigma
exists because health care workers
actually may be at greater risk than
general population but it's sort of
controversial sort of controversial
actually through use of universal
precautions the risk of acquiring HIV in
healthcare settings may be brought
nearly 20 and what else helps us here
what else help helps really avoid
getting infected in healthcare settings
besides universal precautions
don't win the HIV
alright but some sometimes we don't know
besides that without knowing status
first Universal precaution precautions
that's why they are universal we use
them regardless of the status that's a
really nice way to stop discrimination
we always use gloves we use gloves with
any single patient without taking HIV
test first and what will be the second
what yes that's fine yes that's one of
the approaches and I mean it's okay
perfect perfect that's what I was hoping
to hear that there is a post-exposure
prophylaxis so if you take medications
for a months after a contact after risky
contact regardless which kind of contact
is it professional or sexual or drug use
whatever you take medications for a
month and then there is nearly zero risk
that you have HIV so yes I'm here the
strategies how hiv-related stigma can be
reduced these are mostly for public
health professionals and yes as you have
said that knowledge of HIV transmission
and knowledge of it what HIV is can be a
key to design a program knowledge what
stigma is why stigma is harmful and how
to realize that you're stigmatizing is
very important and the third thing is
about moral moral is linking people with
HIV to improper immoral behavior that's
another topic which I can go on for for
a good week
there is a yes yes there is a process
which is called moral disengagement and
if we anyone heard of moral
disengagement yes yes ok I see couple of
hands good moral disengagement is the
process which allows us naturally good
individuals act sometimes really not so
good and it stands on categorization
when we categorize on us and not not us
and them so it's ingrained in our brain
to act nicely towards us and it's okay
it's all so ingrained in our brain it's
okay to not work nicely towards them not
to act nicely towards them so that's the
third thing and I mean it's really
fascinating so there in our brain there
are mechanisms that allow for really
something which is may be seen as really
improper bad things and there are many
examples in the history so you may know
but we we should go closer to the topic
of the study which is stigma expressed
by medical students Sigma by medical
students surely they have they share the
beliefs of the general population of our
country's city wherever they come from
and they further transfer these
attitudes into their practices but at
the same time time I mean medical school
presents an opportunity to teach doctors
how to work in non stigmatizing known
discriminating way and there was there
are studies saying that students
actually willing to learn more students
don't want to be discriminated but there
are also negative findings sometimes
schooling can increase stigma and the
rest studies again one studies was done
one study was done in New York City
showing that schooling a medical school
can actually increase stigma sad but
true okay and why do you think is that
why do you think studying at Medical
School can increase stigma energies
store social status is increasing yes
what's that a confirmation bias
in processes okay okay okay so yes so
kind of they have something prior to
entering the medical school and they
tweaked the knowledge they acquire just
to prove their beliefs all right any
other ideas there is another way which
actually was which actually is described
here in the in this paper reference
number five on this slide any other
ideas
apprenticeship their class
perfectly that's the topic of that of
that paper that professors actually
teach students to be stigmatizing
professors themselves being stigmatizing
have their students learning that all
right so stigma expressed by medical
students is a well-known phenomenon it
varies from country to country and
exists everywhere starting with
developed countries US UK there were
studies confirming existence of stigma
well there were no studies in Russia
devoted to that but knowing the high
level of stigmatization of hiv-positive
people in Russia one can expect that
students will also be pritam quite
stigmatizing do you have any questions
on like general stigma part because now
we move going to move to the results of
the study
alright not too tired okay study
objectives so there were three
objectives of this study first where we
wanted to assess prevalence of biased
attitudes which is another way to say
stigmatizing attitudes among medical
students towards hiv-positive and
marginalized patients second we wanted
to evaluate distribution of this
attitudes among different student
subgroups and we picked gender & year of
study we wanted to compare a level of
stigmatization expressed by medical
students throughout the different
subcategories of patients and we'll
discuss more the categories this survey
was done in Kazan State Medical
University which is medical school in
kazan russia cousin is a city of 1.2
million population so it's relatively
it's it's not too small we have a
medical school there then main study
tool was five-point likert-type scale
and you will see in the next slide you
will see how the scale actual actual
skill looked like and we had nine
vignettes nine examples of the patients
HIV negative medical doctor which was
always a comparison commercial sex with
you and their HIV positive coin so
hiv-positive medical doctor and so on
and we added hiv-positive due to blood
transfusion to have kind of innocent
innocently acquired HIV
so now for epidemiologists study outcome
study outcome was measured meaning the
level of stigmatizing attitudes was
measured by the liquor types scale and
we considered as a reluctance to provide
medical care at least two answers would
not volunteer or would very strongly
choose not to volunteer having neutral
and positive answers as non stigmatizing
approach okay I can give more details on
that if you want but we can do that in
the discussion exposures steady exposure
was we had a number of exposures year of
study here again we used categorization
this is a good way to use categorization
again to simplify not just thinking but
the process of exploring things the
study when we categorize to make things
easier and again to epidemiologist why
we divided into clinical and preclinical
what usually is the kind of ground for
categorization is it our own data or is
it something else
okay we used logical categorization so
up to the year three students don't see
patients and starting from year for
students see start seeing patients
that's why we categorize on that okay
second exposure was students gender and
then additional exposures / potential
confounders concern about HIV about
acquiring HIV in healthcare settings
any questions about exposure and outcome
okay so statistical analysis was pretty
simple after initial cleaning an
assessment we did bivariate and
stratified analysis and then we run a
log binomial regression and to say it's
to put it straight forward this results
are agreed with each other to the very
great extent so we in the presentation
we're going to talk mostly about
stratified analysis and we have just one
slide on the regression because they
basically the same I mean they bring the
same results
all right here are the results
so out of 436 surveys what we had
seventy percent of our students were in
our sample were female what do you think
about this number
is it the same as in the US do you think
the sample was biased do you think we
were recruiting mostly female students
what do you think positions
since I think of what more yes that's
absolutely correct that's the general
distribution of the gender & medical
schools in former Soviet Union majority
of medical doctors in Russia and former
Soviet Union countries are women okay
okay in regard to look over the year of
study we have I mean it's nearly half
and half so fifty five percent were in
clinical years 45 in preclinical mean
age was 20.4 that's the categorization
results we don't stop on that because
we're going to move to the results of
the study themselves the way i would
like to present the results maybe are
not very commonly used so that's why i
would like to spend if you spend a few
minutes on the way the results are
presented okay so this is a cobweb
diagram and for access here and access
represent patients so here commercial
sex worker medical doctor drug user men
who have sex with men and on the axis
you see the level of reluctance to
provide medical care so here for
instance for medical doctor we have just
a few percent of people who said that
they will not volunteer to take care of
the medical doctor okay the percentage
of those who will not volunteer to drip
commercial sex worker you see was much
greater about sixty percent do you see
the idea okay
here we have student category okay and
we categorize students as clinical and
preclinical and male and female and
again to wake up epidemiologists my
question is why we had to present
results in four strata what do we have
here
why don't we lump them all together
yes and how is it called in the bill
epidemiology terms interaction or
affiliation perfect in our data we had
effect modifications that's why we had
to present them in four separate strata
what's that was okay if you look at 100
mothers lumped in with a hundred
father's name look at the exposures it's
not going to tell you what you want yes
exactly affect me yes yes yes exactly so
we had different effects we had
different results among those four
subgroups clinical preclinical male
female students so we will have four
subgroups and to add to that we have
here in the darker color in darker
figure we have results for HIV negative
patients and the in the lighter color
the larger figure we have numbers for
HIV positive patients okay so what will
that mean student who is in clinical
years and female they will be that much
reluctant to treat the doctor if the
doctor was hiv-positive so this is
addition due to HIV positivity of a
patient okay the same for commercial sex
worker drug user and men who have sex
with men all right here are the results
reluctance to treat HIV negative
physician was as we may expect was quite
low just a few percent you see in every
graph so we have preclinical female
reclining on male and so on the
reluctance to treat physicians was low
but if we move to marginalized patients
you see that reluctance was much higher
reluctance to treat was much more
prevalent okay also kind of what we
could expect unwillingness to treat HIV
positive patients everywhere was larger
than unwillingness to treat HIV negative
patients again something that we would
expect but again look at the numbers the
unwillingness can go up to seventy two
percent so seventy two percent of
certain patients potentially can be
refused to healthcare to be provided
with care
any questions on that this is kind of
fun what was expected and that's what we
have seen but we now move to something
interesting in general unwillingness to
treat HIV positive or marginalized
patients was more prevalent among
clinical students so the more you study
the less nice to your marginalized
patients you become that's what we found
these are particularly prominent
differences for example for HIV positive
drug user and willingness to treat from
2654 percent from preclinical to
clinical years
the same for female students again we
see that unwillingness to treat jumps
when you move to clinical years another
finding female students were found to be
more stigmatizing these are differences
not everywhere though not to every
category female students tend to be
nicer to men who have sex with men and
men male students tend to be nicer
guests to whom to sex workers well
that's what it is the same findings in
clinical years any questions on that
before we move to regression
regression okay regressions here so this
was the model building and the only
variable that we excluded from the model
because it was insignificant it was
actually concerned about acquiring HIV
and health settings we excluded it's
from the final model and the regression
results actually really represent the
same idea as the stratified analysis so
we don't really go deep into that the
same so clinical students are more
stigmatizing and so things are the same
limitations as every study because its
limitations our study also did the first
limitation is related to the outcome
definition outcome in this study should
be really seen as stigma in broader
meaning not just straightforward intent
to discriminate but stigma in general
sense what we were talking about at the
beginning of the lecture that stigma is
different behavior may be it may be
expressed in different behavior the
different way we'll look at that patient
different way we act so we also did not
go deeper into the reasons for
reluctance to provide care maybe we will
do in the follow-up studies our study
was done using convenience sampling and
South self-selection bias may be present
but we had response rate around seventy
percent the since we had both prevalence
estimate and prevalence ratio estimate
and they are quite close to each other
we may conclude that if self-selection
bias was present it was not very
prominent convenience sampling has
another consequence that the
probabilistic meanings of the p-value
and confidence interval is compromised
but still confidence intervals and
p-values provide insight into the
precision they don't have exactly
probabilistic meaning but they give you
an idea how precise were emphasized the
results were third limitation is that
results in our study come from one medic
just one medical school and
generalizability may be restricted but
knowing the prevalence of HIV stigma in
the society knowing that it is prevalent
everywhere we can say that results will
be might be the same in
other schools in Russia also any
questions on that
alright we're going to move to
discussion basically a mostly local
students most local students though
there are some from other cities yes
living with HIV or
yes they do yes yes they do I mean they
work with all patients who come to the
clinic and among those patients are HIV
positive
okay discussion so high prevalence of
stigmatizing attitudes towards
hiv-positive patients is not something
unique to Russia for example in the u.s.
in new york city and the similar study
was done I mean the world number of
studies done in the US but the
particularly prominent number was
obtained in New York City in early 90s
that up to eighty percent of medical
students were expressing stigmatizing
attitudes so it's not unique to Russia
and knowing the general attitude in the
society and Russian society towards
hiv-positive people the our findings are
not surprising
but if you ask me why it is so prevalent
we tried and hypothesized why and here
we have for hypothetical reasons for
that and I cannot say which is most
important and which is less but I just
going to present them to you and we can
discuss so first there may be imperfect
infection control in health care
settings at least it may be perceived as
imperfect second low-income and young
make among medical establishment that's
that's a problem doctors in Russia are
not rich doctors are yes Robert can give
you some insights and ideas how does it
look like in the real life and informal
payments it do exist in Russia so and
patients could belong to marginalized
groups they are less likely to bring you
something and maybe that's why they are
discriminated against marginalized
patients may be seen as more difficult
which often is true like drug users they
tend to have more comer abilities than
people who do not use drugs and that's
the most sad but probably is true that
socially it is okay to discriminate
studying in medical school should not
increase stigmatizing attitudes but our
study shows that it does i would say
that there is the question should be
really explored why is that so and we
should work probably with professors and
teachers in medical school
so and that's my personal pet peeve
medical school curricula they usually
focus on clinical sites in medical
school at least in Russia we do not
really spend time on how to talk to
patient how to see patient how to
approach yeah we study endless I mean I
was teaching in medical school in Kazan
for seven years and we give students
endless list of opportunistic infections
endless list of antiretroviral
medications but we hardly spend a few
minutes talking how to approach a
patient so definitely curriculum has to
be changed
any questions on the discussion part we
are nearly at the end so conclusion
majority of medical students in Russia
may have negative attitudes towards
hiv-positive patients most likely they
do have them reluctance to treat appears
to be more prevalent in students of
clinical years of study reluctance to
treat appears to me to be more prevalent
among female students and this finding
suggests that more attention to the
issues needed a more exploration is
needed and I think changes are necessary